foreign
[Music]
not only did John Wick 4 recently take
the popular franchise led by Keanu
Reeves to the magical box office
Milestone of one billion dollars but it
also raised big questions as to what
will happen next Joe Drake the chairman
of Lionsgate has now finally spoken out
about John Wick chapter 5. during
lionsgate's earnings call Drake first
announced that they plan to expand the
John Wick Universe extensively be it
into AAA video games television or other
spin-offs officially four projects are
currently in the works among them are
the movie ballerina the prequel series
the continental and indeed a John Wick
5. the fifth part is to emerge naturally
from the stories of the spin-offs
currently the film is in an early stage
of development but the biggest
unanswered question for fans remains
will Keanu Reeves return for John Wick 5
if Drake's statements are interpreted
correctly we will have to wait and see
what ballerina with Anna dearmus and the
Continental will bring us at least for
the former cameos by Keanu Reeves have
already been confirmed what the
mysterious fourth John Wick project is
was not revealed by Joe Drake however
producer Erica Lee already said at the
end of March that a new film would be
announced roughly two months later
whether that is John Wick 5 or another
film is currently not clear we will keep
you up to date as always
[Music]
thank you